- During the six years I worked
in consulting at McKinsey,
I created literally thousands
of PowerPoint slides,
while working on several
client presentations.
By doing that, I learned lots
of little tips and tricks,
specific elements
that consultants use to give their
presentations the special
professional look that makes it
ready for board room and just distinctive.
When I flip through a
presentation, I can directly
tell you if this is a
presentation from an MBB
consulting firm.
So from McKinsey, BCG or Bain,
or if it's not.
In this video, I'd like to share
the little things with you.
The little tips and tricks,
the little elements that top
consulting firms use to
make their presentations
look like the way they do.
I trust this will really help
you improve your presentations
as well, and give them
the professional touch
and feel that you're looking for.
Hi guys, my name is Heinrich
and welcome to another
coffee break with Firm Learning.
If you're new to this channel,
on this channel I try to
help you become successful
in the first years of your
career by teaching you both the soft skill
and the hard skill to excel
in your first business role.
One of the things I frequently
talk about on this channel,
is how you can excel you skills in both
PowerPoint and Excel.
Because, the truth is that
especially PowerPoint is one
of the tools you will use
most frequently in most
business roles out there.
So, if you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please let's destroy
the like button for the
YouTube algorithm and also
let's leave a comment below.
And of course, please subscribe
to this channel and hit
also the notification bell
to stay up-to-date on all the
content I have planned for you.
I will release at least one video for you
every single Saturday,
and on many weeks there are going
to be two videos coming out for you.
If you're not following
me on Instagram yet,
my Instagram handle is
@firmlearning as well.
On Instagram I'm releasing
new content every single day.
Just giving you a bit
of a behind the scenes
into my personal life and how
I prepare all this content for you.
And on my Instagram I share
even more content that will
help you succeed in the
first years of your career.
Today, I am talking to you
about lots of little tips
and tricks that I learned
as a consultant working
at McKinsey for six years.
I share design principles
that consultants apply for
literally every single
presentation that they use.
Little elements that typically
appear on slides that
almost every consultant use every day,
but that I rarely see on
presentations outside of the
consulting world.
So if you're interested to
learn lots of little tips
and tricks that you can use for your
slide presentations as well.
Look at this video until the end.
And if you're one of those people that are
really interested to take
your slide presentation
game to the next level,
I even released a multi-hour
course and all the
tips and tricks that I learned
at McKinsey on how you make
top management style presentations.
There are already over 10,000 students
taking the course.
If you're interested in that,
I leave a link to the course in the
description down below.
So, if you'd like to learn more about that
and also read lots of student reviews,
feel free to have a look
and check out the course.
But, now let's dive into that.
I prepared a bunch of
slides for you that just
illustrate my points.
Let's now switch to my
computer to have a look
how this looks like.
Alright, let's jump into it.
So let's start with some basics.
Some basic elements
that should be included
on every single page.
So let's start here on the bottom.
What you see here is the date.
The current date.
And pretty frequently
you put here the date
either when the presentation happened,
where you present your pages,
or when you created a document.
Because what you will also
find is that many documents
in professional contexts,
many presentations, many slides,
are not actually created
for actual presentation,
but rather as a document
that is then circulated,
sent around in a company.
And a date is just important,
because when in retrospect,
you're able to actually know,
to understand when the
document was created.
Which of course, is
important in many ways.
The second thing that you'll include on
pretty much every page,
is a page number.
This of course, is very useful if you sit
in a meeting and just a colleague wants
to refer to a specific page.
Then to be able to say okay,
this is a page 18 and then everybody knows
what page 18 exactly is,
because there is a page number
included on the document.
Then of course, is very important.
Next thing you should
look at is the source.
So here you can include a source,
such as Firm Learning.
Of course, you can even
then include, just your name
or your department as a source,
but even better would be
especially if you refer to a
specific data, then also
give the source of the data.
So what date are you using?
Where is the data coming from?
When was the date collected?
Some specific information
on what data you're using
is what you can likely
include here in the source.
The next element that you
can use are footnotes.
So, footnotes, one, two, three,
this is just a part where
you can give specific
details on certain things.
But maybe just not fit in the
regular text on your page.
Then you would just
include it in the footnote
to give you some extra space,
because it's often a smaller font size
than the main page.
Just to show additional remarks.
And of course,
one of the most important elements
of every page is the action title.
The action title is the title of the page.
And creating a good action
title is an art form itself.
Now, I will not go into much of detail
in this video, what a good
action title looks like,
because, I already
created a specific video
only focusing on action titles.
The video even includes
an exercise how you can
improve your action title creation skills.
If you're interested in that,
have a look.
I will include a link
to the video above
so that you can directly look into it.
So far, so good.
So this was some just really bare basics
that should be included in every page.
Let's jump into something else.
And this is the creation of charts.
So what you will see in consulting,
is that almost every slide that you use,
contains a chart.
So some kind of diagram
where you depict data.
The reason is that in consulting,
very frequently, your argumentation
will be based on data.
You can just expect from you,
that you will back up your findings
and your recommendations with
some date-driven analysis.
And if you do these kind of data analysis,
of course, you will
frequently use charts to then
show the results of your analysis.
And these are just the
charts that you can create
with the think-cell expansion.
If you do not know think-cell,
it's a plugin that very frequently is used
by consulting firms to create the charts.
So, almost every consulting firm uses it.
Of course, if you do not have it,
you can just also work with the regular
PowerPoint built-in charts.
If you have the opportunity
to use think-cell,
I can highly recommend it,
because it really improves your workflow.
If you now go over this chart tiles,
many of them you will already know
and probably frequently use yourself.
Such as, stacked bar charts,
or the 100% bar charts,
clustered bar charts, and so on.
Right now, I'd just like
to put your attention to
the waterfall chart type.
So the waterfall chart
type is a chart type
that in consulting,
especially at McKinsey, you
will use all of the time.
So, there's almost no presentation
without a waterfall present.
But, outside of consulting,
I really rarely see it.
Just from my observation.
The fact alone that a
presentation includes a
waterfall chart, very often
is a clear, telltale sign
that a MBB consulting firm worked on it.
And actually, most of the
cases, it has been McKinsey,
because, for whatever reason,
waterfall charts are just so commonly used
by McKinsey consultants.
So, let's look at an example.
So, this is just a basic example
of what a waterfall chart looks like.
And I'd just like to use
this example to show to you
what I believe the waterfall
charts can just be so
helpful in so many business presentations.
So, this of course is
just a stylist chart,
an illustrative chart, so let's not
care about the specific numbers.
But, this is now a bridge chart.
Actually, many people,
instead of using waterfalls,
they also just call them bridges.
So, bridge chart.
Because, waterfall charts are very helpful
to show a bridge.
To show how one number
relates to another number.
One way that this is frequently used
is to show bridges
between financial figures.
So, here we compare the EBITDA.
So, the earnings before
interest text depreciation
amortization of 2019.
To the EBITDA in 2020,
and we like to understand the difference.
And if you just look at the numbers,
here it has been 1.59,
and here it has been 1.67.
So, at first glance, it
could look like the numbers
are pretty similar.
So you could infer,
that actually the company
has been quite stable,
there were many things
that actually changed.
If you don't break down
the difference of these
two numbers, into all the effects,
that actually changed,
from 2019
to 2020.
You'd see that there are quite
some things going on.
So here was one effect that if you use
the EBITDA by 700,
but then this is compensated
by another effect
that increased it by 730.
And there's another positive effect,
further increasing it by 450.
And a reduction by 650,
and then another increase in 250.
So what you can see is
that the waterfall chart
really enables you to breakdown
something into the
different sub components
that were driving it.
And then enable it to
make changes visible,
that were just not visible.
Just looking at the total difference
between two numbers.
Let's now look into another
very ambiguous chart element.
This is a so-called, callout.
This is this element right here.
So, this is an element that you can just
include in a chart.
Gives details about this specific element.
So as I wrote here, it
can include remarks
on specific elements of
a chart or other relevant
contributions that you wanna make.
A callout is something
that you can easily use,
just add details,
add information,
add context to one specific element.
This is a frequent way how you can do it.
So, this element just
consists of one line,
and then another line
with a special ending.
So, if you has never
created this yourself.
I just broke down here the elements here,
you see the line and that this is just
another line, then it's you
can know in the line settings,
you can just add also
such an endpoint to it.
Then if you combine it,
this is what it looks like.
So, this is just an easy way to create
this kind of callout elements.
And believe it or not,
but, callouts like this
will be used in pretty much every single
consulting presentations that you see.
Another element that
might have catched your
attention is something
that is called a sticker.
And this is what you see
here in the top right.
So, a sticker is a qualification of the
page that you use.
Here, you see the preliminary sticker.
So, let's now just go over
some examples of stickers
that are frequently and commonly used.
Then what the context is how you use them,
in the consulting context.
So, for discussion sticker,
the preliminary sticker,
highly preliminary, indicative,
and then illustrative.
So, these are probably the five
most commonly used stickers.
Of course, you could write
other things as well.
And stickers are elements that are
pretty much used to protect yourself.
So, why could this be important?
Why would you need to protect yourself?
So, let's imagine you make an analysis,
which might be a bit controversial,
you know that their resides,
will not please everybody.
And what you can do is,
to include such a for discussion sticker,
then if you walk into a meeting,
then you realize that your analysis sparks
some discussion, and then yet you can say,
well, "Yes, of course, this
is not the final result."
"This is just for discussion."
As you also wrote here.
"So let's just have a
discussion about it."
"I'm interested to hear your opinion."
"What is your view of it?"
"Why do you believe this is true?"
"What is your opinion?"
So, this is how you frequently use
such a for discussion sticker.
Preliminary and highly preliminary,
this is just something to make clear,
that the results that you're showing,
the analysis that you are doing,
are not the final ones.
And here again, this just,
is a way to protect yourself,
that then if later it comes out that
maybe your were missing some data.
That there additional information that you
would need to take into consideration.
You can just say, "Yes, of
course, this analysis that"
"we did here was only preliminary."
"This was not the final version."
This is also again to protect yourself,
because, otherwise, it could happen,
and these things happen, right?
That there is a hostile client,
that then just points out
a page that you created,
maybe in the first weeks
of your engagement,
that you were just learning,
trying to understand the data.
And the page you labeled, you
just did, was complete BS,
because this analysis that you created,
was just obviously not correct.
Right?
And maybe he was right,
maybe it just wasn't correct,
because you didn't have the full picture.
But, then you can say, "Yes,
Mister, this is true, you are"
"right, but as you can also
read here, this was not a final"
"version of the analysis."
"This was just a preliminary version."
And incidents like that happen.
And this is why you put the
preliminary sticker on it.
That's similar, but different
is the indicative sticker
and also the illustrative sticker.
So, an indicative sticker,
you can use just to make
it clear that a certain
analysis that you make,
maybe has some flaws,
maybe has some drawbacks.
So, the numbers that you show,
should not be taken that serious.
But, it gives a good direction,
so that you believe that the analysis,
the results that you
show, are at least are
indicatively right,
and these show the right direction,
the right picture,
even thought the specific
numbers that you use
might not be accurate.
And, this of course can
happen in any situation.
You need to work with
the incomplete data sets,
where you're lacking certain information
that you just were not able to use.
Then, you might want to
make it clear that the
analysis that you're
showing is just indicative.
Illustrative goes kind of
even further than indicative.
And, it's sometimes also
used a bit, in a dirty way,
in the sense that you can
show a whole chart of very
specific information,
very specific graphs,
then you can put an
illustrative sticker on it.
You can make it clear that actually
the numbers are not true.
That you just made up
the whole chart, right?
Maybe, the whole chart doesn't contain
any real numbers at all.
But, you just wanted to
show a certain relationship,
how you believe that it
is from your experience,
or maybe from other
information that you have.
So, you're just drawing this chart,
which maybe not even contains
any real numbers at all,
but illustratively, this
is the chart you believe
it looks like.
So, this is how you put the
illustrative sticker on it.
So, if you see the illustrative
sticker on a presentation,
pretty frequently, you
can assume that actually,
the numbers are not real.
The numbers are not actual numbers.
But, this chart pretty
much just was made up
by the consultant who used it.
So, now another element
that you can frequently use,
is something that is
called a takeaway box.
So, takeaway boxes are something
like this that you
include below your chart.
It includes an important overall remark.
So, while the callout you saw earlier,
usually is used for just
given information on
a specific element of the chart.
If you ever have genuine information,
that is relevant to the whole chart,
you can just include such a takeaway box,
below the chart that you are showing.
In the takeaway box, you can
just include the main insight,
the main piece of information,
that you want the reader,
the viewer, the listener,
to takeaway from the chart
that you are showing.
Another element that you
can use that looks similar,
but is often used in a
slightly different way.
It is something that
you would call a bubble.
So bubble is sometimes
also called a sticker,
and it's included in a
chart in some way like that,
so you purposely make it look like this,
just included in front of something else.
It looks a bit less
informal, than for instance,
a takeaway box.
And, a bubble you often use to include
some kind of limitation
to the analysis that you are showing a
limitation to the data
that you are showing.
And, a bubble is called a bubble,
because sometimes, instead
of a rectangular form,
you can also use a circular
form of the text that
you are showing.
So, that the text is included in a circle,
instead of a rectangular form.
From the standpoint,
bubbles are so important,
you need to put yourself into the shoes
of a consultant.
Because, very frequently, you
receive certain data sets,
certain informations from your clients.
And then you take several days,
or maybe even weeks to
then conduct the analysis,
and then to come up with
some kind of a result.
Then very often, what
happens, is that then,
the last days, some anxious hours before
the big presentation,
where you then want to show the results,
you receive some new information,
maybe you realize that now
some new data came out,
maybe now, the next month's finished,
and now you put, re-do all the analysis,
with all the data from
the new time period,
from the new month.
In these situations, you're
very frequently faced with
the decision to whether
you want to re-do now,
all the analysis,
to incorporate this new
information, or whether,
will you leave all the analysis as-is?
And, then just include
a bubble on the page,
stating the limitation,
or stating what has not
yet been included in the analysis.
Bubbles are so important,
because very frequently,
instead of re-doing the whole
thing, re-doing analysis,
re-creating all kinds of pages.
Problems like that, you can
frequently use with the bubble.
And, this is why there is a
magic saying in consulting,
and this goes like, "If
in trouble use a bubble!"
So, if you are struggling with something,
something just isn't right.
You just need to use this statement,
just need to make some corrections,
in the end, if you're in trouble,
most of the problems you
can just use with a bubble.
Just stating the specific
things that you want to change.
Now, some other frequently used elements
are circles with numbers.
This, again, is something
that I very frequently
see in consulting presentations,
but I rarely see lines of
circles with numbers like that in
presentations that are being
done by non-consulting people.
So, how do you use these things.
So, you can use these kinds
of number circles, whenever,
you want to include another layer of data.
Another dimension of numbers,
which is not directly part of the chart.
So, let's look at this stylized chart.
So, what do we see here?
So, these are the revenue
figures of a business.
But, not the absolute figures,
but the difference to the previous year.
So, we look into these calendar weeks,
and we look into how
the business performed
against the previous years.
So, here, so this would
mean that in the calendar
week seven of the year,
the business had revenues that
were by a 100 million higher
than in the previous year.
You have 200 million
higher, 250 million higher,
here a 100 million less, and so on.
Of course, in this context,
if you look at this,
it would be interesting
and important to us,
to include what the absolute amount,
what the revenue was in
the current year 2020.
In situations like that, where
you just want to include as
a second point of data,
second point of information,
circles of numbers like that
are just very commonly used.
So, here you would now
include information,
that in the calendar week seven,
you make now the revenues of 900 million,
and this was 100 million more
than you made in the previous year.
Then, regarding the
legend, what you do is,
the main legend that you
state in the chart title,
the main legend always refers to the
numbers in the main chart.
And, for the circles, you
can include a sub-legend,
then explain what is shown
and depicted in these circles.
And, if you're interested to
learn more about how to set up
consulting style charts, like that.
I created a whole other
video just discussing
how you should set up the chart title,
then also the subtitle,
and things like that.
So, if you haven't seen that yet,
I believe this is also highly relevant,
and something that you need to know,
if you work in consulting,
or want to create
presentations that meet the
standards of consulting firms.
I will leave it above here for you,
check it out if you'd
like to see it as well.
Next concept I would like
to talk about is also a
very, very important one.
And, it's the concept of clotheslines.
More specifically, of
avoiding clotheslines.
So, what do we call
clotheslines in consulting?
Clotheslines are referred to
as just long lists of things,
and specifically in the context
of creating PowerPoint presentations,
just long lists of bullets.
So, what you will always never see in
consulting style presentations,
is just the list of bullets like that,
where you just randomly
list all kinds of thoughts,
or other explanations that you want to.
So, why is this bad?
So, if you just use a list
of thoughts like this,
what you're missing,
what you're not showing,
what you're not doing, is giving
it some kind of structure.
If you present things like that,
it looks completely random.
The person looking at it,
can have no trust at all
that actually the things
that are mentioned here are complete,
that all the relevant aspects
have been discussed and addressed by you.
But, it just seems like
a completely random
unstructured list of points.
In such an unstructured list of points,
is what you would call a clothesline.
And, you want to avoid clotheslines.
So, what is now used
in consulting to avoid
clotheslines like that?
And, very frequently,
what you do is to use structure elements.
So, here again, just in
the illustrative page,
this could be out of, for
instance, an M&A transaction,
a merger's and acquisition transaction.
Where one company aims
to buy another company.
Another company is showing
how the purchasing price
that they want to offer
for a company splits down
to the different assets
that the company has,
and that the company is selling.
Here again, this is now,
another frequent use of a waterfall chart,
that you now have the
total purchasing price.
Now you show how this breaks
down into the different
subelements of the company.
Now, here you have the different
assets that the company
has to offer us, so here,
property, plant and equipment.
Then, of course, there could
be a whole lot of other
assets that the company offers,
for instance, inventory, and so on.
Now, a clothesline would be
just to state all these assets,
just in a random list of bullets.
Now, to avoid clotheslines,
what you often use is structure elements.
So, what you try, is to define buckets,
to define groups of elements,
then you can use to organize
the different subelements,
that are from bullet points that you have.
Now, here just a simple
example is to use gray bars,
that you include in front of the elements,
then the company you will
often distinguish the
fixed assets from the current assets.
This is now a structure that I defined,
in that, in this structure,
now I can use a different bullet points.
And, I hope you now understand,
that this is superior
to other ways of structuring the points.
Because, now, by having
to use the structure,
fixed assets, and current assets,
I already have some kind of guarantee,
that if I now look at
these two types of assets,
I will catch all the assets
that are included in the company.
Because, this way, now I have covered
the whole balance sheet of the company.
And, I can be sure that
I will have covered all
the assets within these two groups.
So, always use structure elements,
avoid at all costs, using clotheslines,
because, this is just
completely unprofessional.
This is probably one of the
first points of feedback
that you will get as a young consultant.
If you created a page just using
a list of bullet points like this.
So, this concludes my little
list of tips and tricks
of elements that you can use to
improve your PowerPoint pages as well.
I hope you found this was useful.
If you have any questions about that,
feel free to leave me a comment below
in the comment section.
I will answer every single comment,
and I also like to hear from you,
what are your little tips?
What are the things that
you've frequently use
to improve your presentations?
Let's have a conversation here from which
everybody can benefit.
Again, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
This would really help me
and my channel to improve,
to grow, and to tell the
YouTube algorithm that this
is a video worthwhile
for other distributing.
If you are a first time
viewer to this channel,
thank you for your time
and thank you for watching.
Please hit the subscribe button,
you will stay up-to-date.
If you want to see more content like this.
And, if you would like to
make sure that you really see
every single video I've made.
Also hit the notification
bell, because otherwise,
YouTube might not always inform you when
I will release a new video.
And, also, I would very
much appreciate you to
follow me on my Instagram
channel @firmlearning
On my Instagram, I will
share new pieces of content
on how you can be successful
in the first years of your career,
every single day.
So, thank you for watching,
I'm Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I really enjoyed making
this video for you.
I hope you took something
out of it as well.
Thanks again and have a
good day and stay safe.